I think we've established through all
these videos that have a very positive
guy and very win-win and happy happy and
definitely love everybody and everything
but you know sometimes you just have to
talk about things that are a problem and
I just have to call out AT&T I mean more
bars than anybody in the world or
whatever knack that I mean when you say
bars are you meaning that you're
drinking because the fact of the matter
is I am dropping calls everywhere I mean
I like many other people have an iphone
and I didn't hijack you or do anything
to use a different service no I use you
AT&T and I let Verizon which ripped it
which was awesome for me I drop calls in
midtown Manhattan I mean midtown
Manhattan in the 50s and on Madison I
truck calls now in san fran downtown san
fran i'm just in san fran dropping calls
all over the place i'm dropping calls in
seattle i'm dropping calls in austin
texas i'm dropping calls i'm dropping
calls i'm dropping calls so I've just
got to say I have to assume a lot of you
are struggling with AT&T I mean I'm not
looking to hurt 18 these feelings here
I'm not looking for a revolt on the
internet and we're gonna get all our
money back or better service I'm just
shocked bad the service is really and it
just proves how good the iphone is
otherwise because I don't find myself
with that upset you know Apple put
itself in a very interesting position
there are probably other people that are
probably mad at Apple for their
struggles just curious sorry are you
really getting hammered as bad as I am
on AT&T